how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and
everything mcu and today we have our
official
confirmation that haley steinfeld is in
fact playing kate bishop
in the hawkeye series this has been
rumored for some time now and haley even
hinted at it just the other day on her
instagram post
but until today we have not had an
official confirmation but now we do
and not only that but we do have our
first look at kate bishop and hawkeye
together in a leaked
set video and to top it off we have
confirmation that lucky the pizza dog
is indeed going to be in the hawkeye
series as well and he is caught on
camera too
so we'll play the video and break down
everything you need to know in this
video but first if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest mcu news and
leaks and so you can enter this week's
giveaway for a chance to win a black
widow
funko pop from the avengers game so
let's take a look at this video and our
first look at haley steinfeld and jeremy
renner as kate bishop and hawkeye
together
so
so short and sweet but our official
first look now not much to really go off
of here
filming just started for the hawkeye
series and this is one of the first
scenes that they're shooting
now one thing that you can notice is
that hawkeye seems to be kind of leading
her and putting his arm around her a
little bit
it looks to be in a very protective type
of way
and they do seem to be moving in a hurry
down those stairs so what could have
happened here
is that clint or hawkeye is saving kate
bishop in this scene
from who we're not exactly sure there
are rumors that the tracksuit mafia is
going to be in this movie with some
other villains as well
but it does sure seem like he is
protecting her in the scene and
considering the fact that it's one of
the first scenes shot
of the series that's probably the case
and this will probably lead into kate
bishop wanting to be trained by hawkeye
in which he'll agree and kate bishop
will eventually go on to take on the
mantle of hawkeye and have a pretty big
role in the mcu moving forward another
sign that the tracksuit mafia is going
to be a part of the hawkeye series is
the fact that we have
lucky the pizza dog in this video lucky
was originally named ariel when he
belonged to ivan
banyanis and the tracksuit mafia hawkeye
showed arrow some kindness
and when the tracksuit mafia was
shooting at hawkeye arrow attacked one
of the men
the men then beat him and threw him into
traffic but hawkeye rushed him to the
hospital
and he lived he then kept the dog for
himself and renamed him
lucky from there on out he would then be
a pretty big part of both hawkeye and
kate bishop's life
lucky would go on to have a chance
meeting in a park over some pizza that
caused him to team up with
mew the pet cat of squirrel girl's
roommate and lucky and mew would go on
to be a very instrumental part in
defeating taskmaster
so there could also be some tie-ins to
taskmaster and the black widow movie
which wouldn't exactly be surprising but
it does seem like the tracksuit mafia is
going to be a part of the hawkeye series
and now it is officially confirmed
that haley steinfeld will be playing
kate bishop and
lucky the pizza dog is confirmed as well
so let me know what you think about this
leaked video in the comments down below
and let me know what you think about
haley steinfeld playing kate bishop
be sure to like the video and subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest mcu news for live
updates you can follow me on instagram
and twitter and as always thank you all
so much for watching
woof
you